china 6 benvenuti nuovissimo b
però come vedete ci troviamo fuori
perché oggi ha deciso di fare un video
sulle tipologie di camminate non so se
anche voi avete mai fatto caso ma ognuno
di noi ovviamente come in una maniera
diversa e quindi ho deciso di farci un
video se non avete ancora fatto vi
ricordo di iscrivervi al mio canale
attivare la campanella vicino al tas di
iscrizione e alla fine del video il
video vi è piaciuto mi raccomando
lasciatevi un lay che è un commentino
qui sotto e serviva seguitemi su tutti
gli altri social instagram tik tok e
facebook partiamo subito
venite con me
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi io sto facendo una
passeggiata qua c'è un sole pazzesco dio
ho dimenticato gli occhiali da sole
vabbè comunque mi stavo dicendo
[Musica]
qua mi dice che ho già passata ma dopo
allora scusi scusi viale papiniano
allora bella lunga e dc e la lontana da
quella parte
prendo tutta la via grazie scudi
sonorità grazie ma scusa scusa scusa
scusa
[Musica]